e aí galera regional todos vocês aqui
está ótimo porque fui assistir velozes e
furiosos no cinema em mim mas eu fui
convocado e cheguei na cadeia de cinema
primeira coisa que eu fiz o proxy e
segurança pra botar seu filme em 3d e
tem total se de segurança vai com carro
sai da tela tá lá tá seguro segurança do
trânsito do filme velozes e furiosos 6
sabe né porque nos primeiros e sabe que
o japonês morreu a caminho perdeu a
memória já começa o filme assim a minha
perna memória começa a lembrar das
coisas fica com medo e foge com o
cemitério fica lá sentado em um
cemitério que é normal é muito normal se
está com raiva o que você faz amplo
cemitério já sabe que o filho vai ser
bom porque tem 20 dias e um filme tão de
rock the who macho de qualquer forma
aquele uma imagem que o homem lindo da
honra a qualquer folga o de rock sente o
cheiro do perigo ele pelo cheiro sabe se
a pizza de calabresa ou de queijo pelo
telefone tem uma cena de rock bíblia o
piloto calado porque aquele cara também
o papel que lhe cabe é um cara levador
muro de rock e levantar ele não é normal
não o cara que leva dor muito de rock
ele levantar ele pode mudar o nome dele
pra jesus é levantada por um mundo de
rock nessa operação já é ressurreição de
voto uma parede o do inimigo joga uma
bomba que só vai jogar do que ficar só
vez na boca ele joga uma bomba de rock
passar o valor ea companheira dele por
uma loirinha abraça com ela caiu em cima
do prédio em cima de um carro macho
carro hamas igual boston é meu juro a
vocês com derrota e caiu em cima desse
carro escutei o carro dizer ai do homem
é um monstro marcar em cima do caso vai
dando uma luxação no braço o hulk
reversa no supino reto com ele eo paulo
a o o oscar perseguindo os cara tudo pra
morrer explosão toda hora o perigo rola
na guerra rolando a mulher paulo chega
por ele fala assim ele vai lá e acaba
com eles mas só do velozes e furiosos
que a mulher mandou calar ipanema eu sei
que no filme ou indício de mais ou menos
assim umas 15 frase de efeito quando eu
achar não vou decepcionar
esse cara vai pagar por tudo que ele fez
nossas vidas
eu vou encontrar e vou ficar
e bom matar seriam de peixe peixinho é
água mole em pedra dura tanto bate até
que fura logo eu sou seu pai
deus ajuda quem cedo madruga e nada da
ação nada de corrida até que eles estão
lá no velório acho que o velório e ele
vê o moleque doido 2a e começa a
perseguição após perseguição para o
estacionamento fica um de frente por
outro um de frente o outro oscar acelera
contudo encontro hu o cara só faz sair
do carro assim na vida real está
dirigida por um senta esbarrar no
retrovisor de um papo sem morre os caras
não um carro potente tão diferente um
pouco acelera barbat sai do cano máximo
a dor nas costas e que tem uma cena que
oscar apresenta um tal de olho de deus é
como se fosse um gps que encontra
qualquer coisa na face da terra contra
não quero que você encontre a vergonha
na cara dessas menina de 12 anos
cantando funk no facebook o filme
todinha aquela mulher que a mulher do
vídeo que está com problema de memória
toda hora zona para sol aparece forte e
volta vai embora o voto em quem sabe
marcar nada para ninguém sabe que essa
mulher da vida que ela parece a a amora
ilha do sal jorge macho agora uma das
cenas que o cara fica [ __ ] que pariu
[ __ ] vai tomar no meu curso cara pula
os cara pula de avião num carro para
peles andando macho não sei estacionar
um fit 1 nunca faz qualquer coisa com o
catar faz pirâmide com cara de dança
nado sincronizado com o carro mas tem
uma cena de perseguição que é um ônibus
voado um ônibus microônibus voado aí o
paulo walter lá o menino um popular
local decorre em que os caras na
perseguição machucou ao que sai de
dentro do carro ele surfa em cima do
cara o qual ao que surfa em cima do
carro o paulo que é suficiente uma do
carro a 150 por hora
você não pára surfa no carro a cerca de
50 por hora meu dedo no gol sem ficar em
cima de um skate a 10 por hora e o
ônibus voando pra ver o filme em 3d e
machucar brigando dentro do olho papal
filme em 3d o cara cai no chão passa
rolando o [ __ ] mesmo machucou ajuda
ajuda jurídica no sul nenhum dos lados
da ev é macho tem uma cena que dois
carro pula do penhasco
assim acho que eu tenho que pensar
[ __ ] que vista linda em adorei esse
lugar mas que eu vou comprar uma casa
bem por diversos lutar até o carro
capotando penha tatuapé
[Música]
o carro tá só o bolo de bosta no final
do open acho que aí vem o que acontece
salvin disse nenê
aí os caras descobre que o que estamos
procurando é por causa dessa perseguição
do que estão procurando aguardado em um
carro que é blindado e tá lá nos
emirados árabes que as cargas são bem
rico tem aqueles prédios gigantes beleza
os carros lá nós é que mandam há de bom
na festa eles vão tentar fazer tudo na
surdina achar um negócio que estão
procurando do carro e vazar só que quem
é que aparece aquele do que hora que
bateu de rock bateu no vídeo esse cara
está em todo lugar pior que os eleitores
de um satanás carecas cara resolve fazer
e vamos fugir com um carro machos cara
pula um carro de um prédio pru não
satisfeito com esse pulo eles pulam de
outro prédio pra outro feito normal
normal todo dia quando essa aqui em
sobral normal afinal quem foi que nunca
atravessou do espectro car nonô
mas agora na conclusão do filme é o
melhor tem helicóptero perseguindo os
cara pedroni que atira me seu segundo
oscar mas tem uma hora que não dá mais
para se livrar do trono ele vai matar
todo mundo o carro tá voando drone está
mirando ele vai soltar omisso quem é que
aparece um de rock vem com todos na rua
assim a marcha de coke é o de rocha a
ambulância capota e rocks assim ó nessa
cena junto a você me arrepiei do game
aqui não
arrepia os cabelos do curso helicóptero
matilha do botafogo
de repente os tiros um helicóptero que
ninguém é manter o que vem contudo
atira-nos cara tá tomar de rock e
arrastando metralhadora maior do que no
fecho de roma acho que eu vou bater o
poder local agora macho de rock atira
num helicóptero até o helicóptero
explode macho um de rock derrubar um
helicóptero não consegui quebrar uma
lâmpada de um poste eo hezbollah vou
abandonar um link guanabara logo acabe o
final mas no final eu deixo para vocês
verem no cinema é muito emocionante
muito show mesmo o filme tem várias
dessas cenas inacreditáveis dados e kay
matysik mas é por isso que o filme fosse
verdade não era filme era meu filho era
um documentário da banda mas é isso aí
eu achei eu achei que o cara se você
tiver gostar desse vídeo eu quero que
você faça agora pra mim você clica em
gostei aqui no youtube você viu links em
vídeo novo no facebook volta no facebook
clique em curtir marca seus amigos nos
comentários no facebook por desconhecer
o vídeo você já tem assistido pelas
furiosos é como aqui embaixo qual foi a
parte do filme que mais chama a atenção
que você marfim grassar mais
inacreditável como tem pra gente se
esquece se inscrever no canal pra toda
vez que vi um vídeo novo cessar beleza
muito obrigado sgt aqui é nós e um
cheiro de vocês